forme électorale merci de répondre à nos
questions je cite sur les 35 milliards
d'euros de plans de relance sectoriels
de juin 2020 seuls 7 milliards dédiés à
l'emploi occupé par des femmes
avec ce cri d'alarmé qu'est ce que vous
attendez du gouvernement les
associations féministes dont la vôtre
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu un retour
de l'exécutif par rapport à cette étude
n'ont pas encore véritablement mais il
est évident que nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord avec les conclusions de l'étude
qui a été fait par la fondation des
femmes mais peut-être qu'il faudrait
quand même préciser une chose puisque
votre reportage à bord d'énormément de
coin mais il ya un point qui doit être
notre point de départ c'est à dire que
un an après la pandémie mondiale
un constat toutes mes progrès qui avait
pris en matière d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes autant réalité
véritablement régressé et on peut dire
d'une certaine manière que les femmes
sont les victimes collatérales de cette
crise de pandémie alors je m'attarderai
pas sur les chiffres que vous allez
donner mais peut-être on peut quand même
préciser que par rapport à la
concertation qu'a eue le gouvernement
avec un certain nombre disons deux
responsables du territoire ou d'acteurs
sociaux par exemple les associations
féministes n'ont pas été du tout du tout
entendu alors que nous réclamons depuis
un certain nombre d'années qu'au même
titre qu'on reconnaît les syndicats ont
reconnaissent également donc les
associations notamment féministes comme
des partenaires sociétaux et en fait par
rapport à la question que vous me posez
on doit bien que les financements qui
ont été donnés dans le plan de relance
eh bien ces financements elle concerne
des secteurs où les hommes sont
majoritairement présents et très peu de
femmes sont présents dans ces secteurs
on sait très bien que le secteur du
digital et la transition écologique sont
occupés massivement et seront occupées
ma
suivent ma part par les hommes donc le
coeur de ce que nous nous combattons
c'est à dire la société patriarcale pour
arriver à une plus juste égalité n'est
pas du tout mise en cause et ont même
évoqué l'idée d'évoquer le manque de
concertation avec les associations
féministes ou avec les associations
comme vous comme vous dites des
associations il y en a beaucoup
vous avez évoqué les syndicats s'il ya
des concertations avec avec toutes les
associations avec tous les syndicats
avec tout le monde finalement on peut
pas s'en sortir c'est sans fin non pas
du tout pourquoi il faut aussi être un
petit peu moderne et de son temps c'est
à dire que les associations féminines et
féministes depuis 40 ans et même
maintenant 50 ans qu'elles existent ont
montré toutes leurs capacités avec des
forces de proposition absolument
indispensable pour répondre à une
société de moderne et à la compétition
effectivement que doit arriver a assuré
la france en tant que nation qui doit
sortir de cette crise par le haut
bien entendu surtout dans une situation
de compétitivité mondiale de l'économie
néo libérale mondialisée alors sur la
question des plans de relance pardonnez
moi un petit problème de songer pas si
vous nous entendez on a souvent dit
depuis un an que les soignants les
soignantes les pompiers les pharmaciens
les pharmaciennes les médecins étaient
en première ligne dans la crise
sanitaire
on parle en général de corps de métier
là c'est nouveau on évoque le genre
pourquoi elle est dans l'opposition
hommes femmes quant au plan de relance
dans les aides vont d'ailleurs
indistinctement aux deux sexes dans un
but de relancer l'économie
ça veut dire quoi c'est l'économie elle
a pas de sexe non aussi l'économie a un
sexe la preuve même c'est que les
institutions internationales comme par
exemple l'onu ou même l'union européenne
ont préconisé des mesures de politiques
publiques pour faire en sorte
effectivement que le conomie soit genre
et comme
c'est à dire qu'on regarde l'économie
avec une approche féministe un oeil
féministes ou en mettant les lunettes du
genre si vous voulez qui permettrait
effectivement d'avoir des résultats
beaucoup plus en terme d'égalité et ça
c'est pas les associations qui veulent
qu'ils le demandent
ce sont des textes internationaux qui
doivent être appliquées par les états
par exemple l'économie jean rey s'est
passée sa place et essayer de voir dans
tous les secteurs de l'emploi de quelle
manière on arrive à faire de l'école de
l'égalité femmes hommes et si on
n'arrive pas à la faire de prendre des
mesures
ça existe ça existe dans un certain
nombre de pays déjà par exemple le comme
la suède qui est beaucoup plus loin même
que l'économie gendre et c'est à dire
qu'elle applique ce qu'on appelle le
gender budget thing
c'est à dire de donner des finances pour
favoriser l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes dans un certain nombre de
domaines au niveau justement de
l'économie et l'économie et les gens
mais ne serait ce que par rapport au
fait que les femmes font beaucoup plus
de travail domestique et que c'est un
travail gratuit entre guillemets ou du
secteur informel et que si on arrivait
par exemple avoir exactement la plus
value ou la valeur
qu'importe ce travail est bien
effectivement serez obligés de modifier
considérablement le produit intérieur
brut des nations par exemple dans le
l'étude qui a été publiée hier son cité
plusieurs exemples pour prendre en
compte la spécificité des femmes par
exemple les violences conjugales les
inégalités face aux salaires etc
est ce que le plan de relance générique
de
tiens compte de ces disparités est ce
qu'il faudrait pas plutôt une loi
spéciale pour un meilleur accès à
l'emploi pour les femmes par exemple
dissocier les deux en gros il ya déjà
une bras en principe qui existe depuis
1984 en france et la loi de l'égalité
professionnelle
cette loi de l'égalité professionnelle
elle n'est pas appliquée donc déjà
commençons par appliquer les lois
vous savez aujourd'hui dans notre
société il ya toutes les situations par
rapport à la question et du harcèlement
et des violences faites aux femmes ont
mis tout est un exemple frappant
justement d'un prolongement
générationnel au mouvement féministe des
années 70 qui a obtenu les droits la
contraception et à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse qu'en france
mais il y a également très fortement
chez les jeunes en particulier
garçons et filles qui ne consitue ne
comprennent pas pourquoi
de nos jours alors qu'ils sont très
instruits qui sont capables d'exercer
toutes les professions il y a encore
entre 25 et et 13% d'inégalité de
salaire en fonction des professions donc
je crois que non seulement ce serait
appliqué la loi mais répondre à des
aspirations qui sont très très fortes
dans notre société et que la société
sera obligé de résoudre parce qu'on ne
pourra pas continuer de cette manière
merci monique dental d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
la présidente du réseau féministe
ruptures